[Applause]
oh
yeah happy Thursday oh I love you all
ready so Boston's top donkey wants
Christmas without a
honky this week the mayor's office sent
out an email invite to members of the
Boston city council it was an invitation
to and this is isn't my wording it's
what the mayor said to an electeds of
color holiday party yeah she was making
a list of everyone who isn't white but
to her embarrassment the invitation went
to the entire city council even the
white
folks that's right in 2023 the mayor of
one of America's biggest Democrat run
cities through a racially segregated
holiday bass that would have made George
Wallace
proud you know good thing they didn't
call it a Christmas party right that
would be
offensive me I'm still waiting on the
Muslim
Hanukkah although you have to translate
from The River To The Sea into
Hebrew but really menora that sounds
sexist I'm sticking to my wh's only
Quanza bash Steve Ducey is making his
favorite gumbo and it goes great with
crackers yeah but right after the invite
went out the aid who sent it quickly
realized her error and followed up with
this quote I did send that to everyone
by accident and I apologize if my email
may have offended or came across as so
sorry for any confusion this may have
caused now you notice she doesn't
apologize for shunning people for their
skin color there's no apology for that
blatant racism nope she's just sorry
that the evil white people found out she
made bigotry sound like a clerical error
and don't you love how it's always sorry
for any confusion sorry there's no
confusion for this for anyone with a
brain the racism was easier to spot than
Dylan waney at the Million Man
[Laughter]
March but I wonder is the mayor
concerned this lens itself to further
divisiveness you concern this lens
itself at all to further
divisiveness no I mean um again this is
a a a group that has been in place for
many many years years we want to be a
city where everyone's identity is
embraced and that there are spaces and
communities that we can help support and
what an Embrace this is to divide people
into non-white versus non-invited
but this division did shatter one
stereotype that Asian people are good at
math usually to be that clueless he'd
have to be the president of Harvard or
at least a graduate from there and would
you know it Michelle is she got two
degrees from Harvard one for Law and one
for having her head up her
ass
yeah I think they call that
Premed so it's no surprise she's a bigot
she's from the same woke meat grinder
that turns fresh Minds into the mush
that protects Pro Professor gay and sees
anything white as evil colonizers but as
a defense woo also said that you know
there are many ways to celebrate yeah
and they're only racist some of the time
just like Jimmy
Kimmel but then why was this party
supposed to be secret and is is there a
party that only white people can attend
of course not and there shouldn't be the
music would be
terrible but that's the point racial
segregation is bad no matter which race
is behind it you know we keep hearing
about hostile work environments so how
are are separate parties not hostile
work environments the answer is in the
question in a hostile work environment
nobody even the top execs will ever
complain about it because it's a hostile
work environment the hostility can turn
on you at any
time no wonder these diversity programs
have been shown to increase wor
workplace conflicts and that's according
to a piece from of all places the
Harvard Business
Review but this isn't woo a first woke
disaster in March of 2022 she said this
during a St Patrick's Day event winter
was pretty intense trial by snow trial
by fire fighters
Union I'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and
[Music]
white in your face
firefighters what you think running into
burning buildings makes you some kind of
hero white d
but mayor woo isn't solely to blame
she's only doing what everyone else in
her orbit believes they're all Neo
racists turned out a higher ed
institutions like Harvard and the rest
segregation is back the only difference
is that this time it's okay because it's
not being led by white people white
people are privileged so they get left
out of parties scholarships jobs and
when they're victims of hate crimes the
media blames the Ford Escape remember
that it's a car colleges have black only
safe spaces without white people they're
the only ones considered for Biden's VP
and Supreme Court picks and if you're
white good luck dating a
Kardashian so we now judge by skin color
not character remember when it was the
opposite when a very wise person said
one day may you be judged not by the
color of your skin but by the content of
your character it wasn't Professor gay
who said that although you can bet she
said she did in her thesis
[Applause]
of course if you call out mayor woo for
racism you'll be called racist you're
the bad guy for wanting desegregation in
2023 America and yet a load of whites
voted for her as they also voted for Liz
Warren when they thought she was Native
American stupid pale face
so how about giving those crackers some
credit mayor woo after all they're your
constituents they let you march in the
St Patrick's Day Parade you don't have
to be Irish you just have to be
drunk really makes you wonder how many
other American cities are doing this
crap we only know about this one because
the staff are screwed up but give credit
to Mayor woo for destroying Asian
stereotypes she may be the first Asian
person in the history of the world with
an IQ under 70
I guess the mental illness of liberalism
doesn't discriminate unlike
[Applause]
her let's welcome tonight's guest he was
on SNL before it stood for sorry
nobody's laughing comedian and star of
the new movie daddy daughter trip Rob
Schneider wait a second if he's here
who's picking up Rob Schneider's dry
cleaning actor writer and comedian Jamie
lissow she's frail pale and won't
register on a scale New York Times
bestselling author and Fox new
contributor
ctiv and to him every house is made of
gingerbread New York Times best-selling
author comedian and former NWA world
television CH T that
champion all right Tyrus I knew I knew
that he was going to come to me first
for this so I am prepared
fellas
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
that reaction is what's wrong with
America I have a black zone no Whitey
area and
99.9% of the audience is white tonight
and they said yay good for you we can't
come in your fort it it's a fort and
guess what what it's lonely in here
mhm
she's married to a white man I just like
to point that out too are we sure this
is not a ploy because your husband's the
guy who drinks too much and ruins the
party cuz I'm always told you can't come
to things because there's no tattooed
people allowed and you know what they
say it was a plus one and she probably
could tell her husband you can't come
you're white and here's the thing nobody
wants to ever have a Christmas party
without white guys yeah they're the ones
who do all the stupid you talk about for
the rest of the year like
who do you think's the guy who's going
to get on the Xerox machine not
us cow tipping was invented by goofy
drunk white guys at Christmas parties so
all
see so idiot if you if I had a black
only Christmas party me Charles Payne
Harris
fuler Lawrence Jones and guess what what
it'd be
boring
you forgot Jesse Waters he's 1% black or
so he
claims this is the mo this is the most I
don't know DNA but I am 1 million per
sure you might be negative
one all right Rob by the way
congratulations on daddy daughter trip
this looks like a great movie I'll be
watching it on my DVD tonight thank you
they still make them I hear yes they do
yes and it's available for digital
downloads but the thing is look I'm
offended that anyone is allowed to talk
about Asians here since I'm the only
person that's part Asian yeah that's
true I should be allowed can you imagine
though the dream of the KKK when it was
all falling apart there can you imagine
like you know what we could do CL we
could do this Vern we try this one we'll
tell them black people and them people
the color that they' safer for them to
be separate from us and then they can
have parties separate and then we
segregate them again they'll never never
be too stupid to fall for
that um and people forget how I know but
seriously Asians are are racist they're
the most racist really yes my mother
Filipino she used to add a syllable to
the word black she wouldn't just say
black she' go
black she would she she would add it and
um they were racist Asians are Asians
are racist black um she was B she was
racist against other Asians yeah my
mother would actually say I don't trust
him why he's
Filipino aren't we Filipino yes I don't
trust us
either that's your brother watch
him I love this
show Jamie does this remind you of your
family's annual no Jamie Christmas
party
oh jam I normally wouldn't do this but
you can come
in that's really nice uh how long is
that going to stay up by the way I know
forever so Jamie what are your thoughts
it was word I felt like it made me feel
like a little bit bad when you said the
no Jam own thing and then the way Rob
laugh made me feel
worse it was like the joke is um you
have to be by the way my favorite you
know how I always do my favorite phrase
from your monologue my my favorite F
phrase from today's monologue was Mo
woke meat grinder MH let you know that
that was actually the name of the gay
breakfast place we'd go to a college
[Applause]
um isn't the problem with this for real
it's it's the um it was honest mistake
but the way she phrases it it's like it
would be like if you cheated on someone
and then you you said to the person you
were dating you go like oh my God you
finding the condom was an honest mistake
right like it doesn't apologize for the
thing that she did wrong you have to be
careful with your reply all though yeah
this is one of those things where maybe
she repli this happened to me once I'm
not even once when I was married my wife
emailed me and it said like we should
have an intimate night we should do like
a date night and have and by mistake she
sent it to
[Laughter]
me wow I'm all for racism though and
it's stuff I I don't want to go to
anyway right yeah you know I'm all about
no white at the Christmas part I'd be
like no whites at the craft store I'm
in no whites in the changing area when
your wife's trying not to dress fine all
about it all right you know uh cat um
here's an interesting question do the
officials of color get to go to two
parties or have to go to two parties yes
have to no Tyrus I think that you're
right about the fact that she just
doesn't want her husband to go to the
party yeah because her her husband is
not just white he's like Todd pyro White
oh that white yeah I'm looking at a
picture of him right now on my phone
he's got his polo shirt tucked into his
khakis that that's more white than Tom
shaloo yeah so I just would love to hear
the conversation at the house no no no
you're not you're not coming to this one
honey you can't come to this this is the
no whites
party and if it's been going on for
years that means she's been telling him
that for years yes exactly and he's like
okay I don't know I think whatever but
it has to be about that I think it's
always goes back to something more like
that somebody didn't want their husband
to come or their wife to come and the
whole no honey it's fine you don't have
to you don't have to go was it working
so they had to think of something else
and then this is that's what they
thought of yeah that's why they always
tell me oh this is a party for tall
people but yet Dana Pino's there yeah
then I see Pino on Instagram yeah it's
not fair that's right though I feel like
I'm starting to think like the no Jamie
party is just for
me all right we got a on that was a
great segment and a great audience hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else